formule 1 mika qui ne remporte le grand
prix du brésil suivi par david coulthard
victoire des mclaren mercedes le plus
grand pont de l'europe un trait d'union
vers le futur avec l'inauguration près
de lisbonne de ce fonds de 17 km de long
construit par une entreprise française
la france se fait son ménage de
printemps plusieurs milliers
d'opérations de nettoyage de
l'environnement des milliers de tonnes
de déchets en tous genres ramassé par
des bénévoles pour éviter les mauvaises
surprises les locations de vacances
désormais estampillé par un label de
qualité différentes clés en fonction de
la grandeur et du confort des
appartements celle en quête de ce
journal et puis cinéma avec l affiche le
dernier film de tarantino avec robert de
niro après reservoir dogs et pulp
fiction palme d'or à cannes voici djak
hip hop voilà monsieur bonsoir comme
l'on pouvait s'y attendre écrasante
victoire des mclaren mercedes au grand
prix du brésil de formule 1 qui vient de
s'achever
mika hakkinen avait signé le meilleur
temps des essais il est arrivé en tête
le doublé gagnant avec david coulthard
toujours sur mclaren compte rendu de la
course laurent frédéric bollée être
pilote mclaren en ce moment c'est de la
rigolade david coulthard avant le départ
c'est sans doute que c'est encore un bon
tour qui va être jouée à la concurrente
pour l'écossé néanmoins le problème
s'appelle mika hakkinen le finlandais a
signé la pole position il ne rate pas
son envol
on ne sait pas si le pacte entre les
deux pilotes est encore d'actualité
toujours est il que c'est bien qu'ils
n'aiment qui prend d'emblée une option
pour la victoire
les mclaren qui même sans leurs systèmes
de freins directionnelle jugée non
réglementaire effectue alors une
promenade de santé aquitaine et une
seconde plus vite que tout le monde
la domination des mclaren mercedes est
outrageante derrière ce sont
classiquement les premiers abandons
dommage pour la prost de trulli pour
c'est aussi plus spectaculaire pour ralf
schumacher en tête
rien ne semble pouvoir arrêter aquitaine
un seul arrêt aux stands c'est sans
problème
le finlandais parti pour la troisième
victoire de sa carrière le plus beau
moment de la course est à mettre au
crédit de alexander würz il se
débarrasse de frenzen en plongeant à la
corde
c'est super tu d'audace et de contrôle
abandon également pour olivier panis en
fin de course
aucune prost ne rejoint donc l'arrivée
le seul suspense concerne alors la météo
on annonce une averse au dessus de sao
paulo
mais le ciel reste relativement clément
et les mclaren signé un nouveau doublé à
qui mène devant coulthard schumacher et
troisième source
franzen et fisichella villeneuve n'est
que 7e akin n est en tout cas l'homme à
battre désormais et pour l'instant les
week-ends de grands pays se suivent et
se ressent en france le grand nettoyage
de printemps avec pour la quatrième
année consécutive plusieurs milliers
d'opérations ville et campagne propre
les balayeurs de la nature se sont
retrouvés aujourd'hui pour ramasser plus
de 100 mille tonnes de déchets une
contribution des bénévoles jean claude à
la milk
une leçon choses pas très ragoûtante
pour ces collégiens alsacien et une
pêche pas vraiment miraculeuse pour ce
grand nettoyage de printemps organisée
dans toute la france inventaire à la
prévert tout et n'importe quoi de vieux
vélos des appareils ménagers des
vieilles télés et encore et toujours du
plastique n'est pas de [ __ ] laveur il
ya longtemps qu'ils ont fui la pollution
sur les berges de la seine autour de
l'île saint denis on avait mobilisé les
grands moyens avec deux bateaux
poubelles dissimulés dans les
broussailles
une carcasse de voiture est repérée sans
l'intervention du commando de bénévoles
elle serait sans doute resté là de
longues années sont dépassés et se
renvoient à une mobilisation pour la
bonne cause et pour tout le monde
les gros bras comme les petites mains et
les écologistes en herbe ne sont pas les
derniers à penser à leur futur enfant
après une journée comme ça on est très
fatigué mais on dit au moins dans notre
journée on a fait quelque chose on a
rendu service
sur la rive a laissé un lieu comme sa
propre
il restera propre peut-être pendant
quinze jours trois semaines mais c'est
ce qui est gagné sur la pollution qui
coachent inouï de plus en plus quant à
s'attaquer à la pollution de la mer
c'est un break tonneau des danaïdes
pourtant à biarritz pour n'a pas hésité
à se jeter à l'eau et a écumé la plage
ce n'est peut-être qu'une goutte d'eau
pour préserver notre environnement mais
c'est le geste qui compte
au portugal inauguration aujourd'hui du
plus grand pont de l'europe jeté entre
les deux rives du tage près de lisbonne
17 km pour cette architecture futuriste
qui porte le nom du navigateur portugais
vasco de gama dont on célèbre le 500e
anniversaire de la découverte de la
route maritime vers les indes
c'est une société française qui a
réalisé cet ouvrage qualifié d'un des
plus grand chantier du siècle après le
tunnel sous la manche
alban nicosie sans aucun doute
voici l'un des ouvrages marquants du 20e
siècle difficile de comparer ce pont à
quoi que ce soit disons simplement qu'il
est assez long pour enjamber tout paris
il relie désormais les deux rives du
tage au nord-est de lisbonne tout près
du site de la prochaine exposition
universelle
cet après midi il a été inauguré en
grande pompe par le président portugais
jorge sampaio qui ensuite invité les
délégations à bord d'un autobus que
n'aurait pas désavoué des beatles au
zénith de leur carrière pendant 48
heures les ouvrages et d'accès gratuite
dès mercredi il coûtera aux
automobilistes 320 excuses hausse soit
près de 10 francs pour l'emprunter taxe
relativement faible pour un ouvrage qui
donne le vertige 17 km de long 840
pilier six voies de circulation et le
dernier cri de la technologie française
notamment ces coupleurs hydrauliques qui
relie piliers et tablier ils sont conçus
pour amortir les effets d'un éventuel
tremblement de terre d'un coût total
proche de 6 milliards le pont a
bénéficié d'un tiers de financements
européens
ce qu'on représente ainsi le lien entre
nos peuples et surtout avec nos
partenaires européens en quatre ans plus
de 3000 personnes ont travaillé sur le
chantier dont 150 ingénieurs français du
groupe campenon bernard
l'ouvragé est indiscutablement une
réussite technologique lui reste
désormais à prouver sa rentabilité
alerte à la bombe dans le tunnel sous la
manche cet après-midi deux colis
suspects à l'origine de l'évacuation des
passagers de la navette qui circulait
dans le sens grande bretagne france les
artificiers sont intervenus mais il ne
s'agissait que de boîtes emballés dans
des journaux le trafic a repris
normalement
l'absurdité de la violence sur les
stades britanniques avec pierre la mort
d'un jeune homme à la sortie d'un match
de football trois suspects interrogés
la victime aurait été mortellement
touché lors d'une bagarre entre
supporteurs et vos isabelle steiss le
match fut houleux et la fin tragique
c'est ici à la sortie du stade hier soir
qu'un jeune anglais de 20 ans est mort
vraisemblablement poignardé lors d'une
bagarre entre une cinquantaine de
supporters plusieurs d'entre eux blessés
ont été hospitalisés
il n'y a pas de mots pour exprimer les
remords mes pensées vont à la famille de
la victime
rien de tel ne s'était jamais produit à
gillingham auparavant il n'y avait
jamais eu de violence entre les deux
samedis sombre journée sur les stades
anglais des matches marqué par la
violence
ainsi lors de la rencontre de première
division barnes et liverpool
insupportait rentrer sur le terrain et
s'en prend à l'arbitré qui devra être
évacué encadrés par les forces de
l'ordre
au milieu d'une foule hostile au même
moment sur un autre stade
c'est un autre arbitre qui manquera être
étranglée par un supporters hooliganisme
absurde ont déclaré les autorités
britanniques qui ont bien du mal à
maîtriser leurs fanatiques
car si la violence et le football ont
une histoire commune en grande bretagne
depuis des années 70 les autorités ont
déployé de gros moyens systèmes de
surveillance sophistiqués unités de
scotland yard spécialement chargé de
suivre à l'année les supporters
dangereux une rigueur qui n'empêche pas
les incidents même à l'extérieur comme
ici à rome en octobre dernier alors que
la coupe du monde approche
l'inquiétude grandit d'autant que ces
derniers mois
c'est tout un arsenal qui a été saisi
sur les pseudos amateurs de football
britannique est aujourd'hui
londres va même jusqu'à demander à la
france de retirer de la vente les canifs
orné du logo coupe du monde 98
l'actualité politique avec cette
question y at il encore une chance de
sauver l'udf déchirait tout au long de
cette semaine entre ces querelles de
famille et d'héritage la question de
l'avenir de la droite se pose
aujourd'hui pour françois bayrou
présidente de force démocrate de ce soir
il prône un référendum auprès des
militants dans un délai d'un mois
il était l'invité du club de la presse
de repas écoutant je dis donc qu'il est
très simple d'écrire sur ces deux points
un texte de référence de quelques nids
en visant premièrement voulez-vous que
l'udf se fixe désormais comme règle
qu'elle ne pactisera pas avec pour faire
des majorités avec l'extrême droite
deuxièmement voulez-vous que l'udf
s'unissent en une formation politique
nouvelle françois bayrou a également
confirmé que charles millon serait exclu
jeudi prochain de l'idheap s'il n'avait
pas dit s'il a démissionné de la
présidence du conseil régional de rhône
alpes
c'est dans ce contexte de crise ouverte
que jacques chirac commencera dès demain
ses consultations sur la modernisation
de la vie politique ou courtes de ces
rendez vous serait abordé la réforme du
mode de scrutin notamment des régionales
première consultation avec françois
léotard pour cette folle semaine qui
pourrait marquer la fin de l'udf j'évite
humbert
je ne peux que désapprouver celles ou
ceux qui ont pré
rés les jeux politiques à la voix de
leur conscience
jacques chirac est descendu dans l'arène
crise politique oblige crise sans
précédent au sein de la droite cassée
par le jeu du fn pour quelques
présidences de région cher pays
l'udf tout spécialement n'en finit plus
de régler ses comptes
les présidents élus grâce à l'extrême
droite doivent démissionner mardi
cette ligne est défini à paris fermement
par françois léotard de procédure à ce
moment-là d'exclusion serait engagé
après réflexion par alain madelin
attentif au cas de charles milhaud
meilhon est un homme d'honneur qui ne
pourra pas gouverner la région qui doit
en tirer les conséquences
mais sur le terrain les intéressés n'ont
que faire des consignes parisienne
et pas question de démissionner l'udf
n'a plus d'autorité l'udf n'existe déjà
plus dans l'esprit de françois bayrou
qui dans la confusion ambiante trouve
urgent de lancer un nouveau parti même
valéry giscard d'estaing son fondateur
semble ne plus croire à l'avenir de
l'udf
le parti doit se déterminer en ce début
de semaine finalement deux présidents
démissionner jean pierre soisson
bourgogne bernard harang en région
centre il ya la pression des états
majors il ya aussi celle de la rue les
manifestations anti fn rassemble
plusieurs dizaines de milliers de
personnes
moderniser la vie politique à partir de
demain jacques chirac reçoit donc tous
les grands leaders à l'exception de jean
marie le pen cumul des mandats
changement des modes de scrutin parité
hommes femmes la compétition elysée
matignon reprend ses droits
lionel jospin s'exprimera sur tous ces
thèmes après les consultations du chef
de l'état enfin la rencontre officielle
il neige et ce par neste antoine
seillière depuis le 10 octobre les deux
hommes n'avaient pas engager le dialogue
sur la question des 35 heures demain à
la veille d'un nouveau vote de
l'assemblée nationale le premier
ministre recevra donc à matignon le
président du cnpf chacun tentera de
persuader l'autre d'assouplir sa
position
laurent bay
un président du cnpf déterminé à faire
assouplir la loi sur les 35 heures un
premier ministre ou non moins déterminé
à la préserver la rencontre entre lionel
jospin et ernest antoine seillière
s'annonce orageuse dans ce rapport de
force
le patron des patrons dispose d'une arme
redoutable la dénonciation des
conventions collectives
ces textes procure aux salariés des
conditions de travail plus avantageuses
que le minimum légal en menaçant de
revenir sur ses acquis et ernest antoine
seillière espère infléchir la position
du gouvernement soucieux de paix sociale
à titre d'avertissement il a d'ores et
déjà dénoncé les conventions dans les
banques l'industrie du sucre et le
commerce en centre-ville fermeté donc
mais sur le terrain dans les pme de plus
en plus d'employeurs ignore la consigne
du cnpf de ne pas négocier et discutent
avec les syndicats les modalités du
passage aux 35 heures le gouvernement
mise sur ce dialogue mais sa force c'est
que le débat parlementaire a déjà eu
lieu
le projet de loi déjà votée sera
définitivement adoptée en mai pourtant
le gouvernement est lui aussi confronté
à une fronde les échéances électorales
passées des députés verts communistes et
une partie du groupe socialistes veulent
maintenant durcir le texte dans un sens
défavorable aux employeurs lionel jospin
et un essai en coin de sellières auront
matière demain à souligner leurs
contradictions respectives quand on
reparle des emprunts russes avec
aujourd'hui ces états généraux qui ont
regroupé à paris plusieurs centaines de
petits porteurs qui dénonce une fois
encore la lenteur des procédures en
france 200 à 400 mille personnes
détiennent ces emprunts on leur promet
d'indemniser année apprennent et demain
le thème sera abordé à l'assemblée avec
l'examen d'une loi d'indemnisation se
fumer elle françois granet en ce temps
là la france croyait en l'avenir au
placement les spéculations allaient bon
train
des millions de bas de laine se
délièrent attirés par l'exotisme des
investissements étrangers
les emprunts russes remportèrent le gros
lot des milliards de francs or 30
millions de titres garantis par les
pillards
mais au lendemain de la révolution de 17
lénine tirer un trait sur la dette des
romanov
des dizaines de milliers de petits
porteurs sont ruinés c'est quand même 80
ans plus tard les fils petit fils de ces
investisseurs bafouée continue de se bat
mais 97 la russie accepte de verser 2
milliards de francs à peine 1 % du
montant total de l'encan pourtant pas un
kopeck n'a été distribué 1 % de ce que
ça peut valoir
je sais que c'est important d'être allé
aujourd'hui
oui je crois qu'il faut maintenir la
pression nous demandons la répartition
immédiate de l'acompte versé par la
russie et nous luttons en plus court
vraiment intégrale de nos pères 2 à 4
millions de titres seraient encore en
circulation pour combien de porter c'est
ce que la loi devra déterminer le
recensement prendra six mois
supplémentaires
les héritiers qui ne désarme pas j'ai
des lettres qui sont assez poignante de
joindre ma ma grand mère mon grand père
mon arrière grand père s'est suicidé
parce que ils avaient tout perdu
je trouve qu'on peut faire quelque chose
aussi pour eux un jour peut-être ces
coupons de monopoly retrouvons de la
valeur alors les moins patients ceux qui
les ont déjà convertis en papier peint
n'auront plus qu'à se mordre les doigts
à saint dié dans les vosges l'incendié
d'un appartement dans une hlm de la
ville a provoqué la mort de deux enfants
en bas âge et d'un adulte
le feu s'est déclaré à l'intérieur de
l'habitation où se trouvait onze
personnes au moment du drame
les flammes se sont propagées rapidement
une quarantaine de sapeurs pompiers à
pied d'oeuvre
une enquête a été ouverte les vacances
des français entre les maths des
professionnels du tourisme à la porte de
versailles jusqu'à demain soir parmi les
initiatives les plus marquantes ce label
de qualité qui permet de classer selon
des critères les plus sérieux les
locations de vos futures vacances pour
tenter de mettre fin aux arnaques en
tout genre des clés à la manière des
étoiles dans les hôtels com barème ou
classement des locations celle en quête
de notre journal alain douguet alain du
bas
c'est dans le gard département à
vocation touristique que l'idée du
classement des meublés vacances a germé
il ya deux ans l'an dernier un arrêté
ministériel officialise ce classement et
l'étend à tous les départements qui en
font la demande
aujourd'hui 44 départements proposent
20000 location de vacances labellisé
regroupés au sein de la fédération
nationale des locations elle établit un
classement de une à quatre clés comme
pour les étoiles d'hôtel les
propriétaires doivent en faire la
demande
un technicien est chargée de contrôler
la qualité des lieux il décide du nombre
de clés premier exemple un studio mode
est situé à 500 mètres de la mer
2300 francs la semaine en juillet août
ici nous sommes dans un équipement et en
catégorie 1 catégorie on veut dire
l'équipement simple mais enfin donc dans
le séjour vous avez un l'histoire pour
un couple parti défi j ai une et
gazinière un four et un frigidaire
partie coin repas disons une table avec
les quatre chaises et puis nous avons
une partie couchage pour enfants avec
des lits superposés une salle d'eau et
wc
deuxième exemple plus chic et plus près
de la plage 2500 francs la semaine en
juillet août cinq couchages alors là
nous sommes dans un studio qui est
classé en catégorie 3 clés dans la
catégorie confort nous tenons compte
aussi des prestations autant dans des
prestations de literie il doit y avoir
eu une literie qui doit être impeccable
très confortable nous tenons compte
aussi de la télévision du téléphone de
l'environnement puisque la voyez ici
c'est un quartier relativement très
calme avec une vue sur le chenal dans un
équipement qui justifie cette catégorie
dans les directions départementales du
tourisme fournissent les adresses ces
locations labellisés par l'intermédiaire
des offices de tourisme
ce classement était devenue
indispensable on s'est rendu compte il
ya une douzaine une quinzaine d'années
que la qualité des équipements qu'on
mettait sur un marché ne correspondait
pas la qualité que nos clients touristes
étaient en droit d'attendre de
l'hébergement de vacances par nos
départements alors ceux qui n'ont pas le
réflexe de louer avec un label qu'elle
recoure ont-ils en cas de cas déception
s'ils ont un problème dans la zone des
autres départements
n'hésite pas à s'adresser au comité
départemental de tourisme aux offices de
tourisme ou au service de la
consommation et de la répression des
fraudes avec la généralisation
progressive des contrôles avant location
les mauvaises surprises devraient
disparaître dans l'aïr pays pour le prix
d'un studio en bord de mer on trouve de
petites maisons
exemple ici 1700 francs la semaine en
juillet août pour quatre personnes
c'est une autre façon de voir les
vacances enfin cette fois c'est un peu
plus cher
l'arrière pays proposent également ce
genre d'habitation celle dont on rêve en
feuilletant les magazines en bord de mer
ces locations classées 4 clés seraient
inaccessibles au plus grand nombre
ces grandes maisons divisé en plusieurs
parties indépendantes seul ou de 4600 à
7000 francs la semaine pour six à huit
personnes
ici tout est déjà réservée jusqu'au mois
d'octobre la saison peut commencer entre
la france et l'angleterre un nouveau
pont culturel avec l'organisation de
stages pour les enfants venus des côtes
françaises juste la manche a traversé
pour tenter d'apprendre dès l'âge tendre
la langue l'anglais ce reportage 8,7 à
l'heure où d'ordinaire le mercredi les
enfants des écoles sont encore au lit
une dizaine de petits courageux
s'apprête comme chaque semaine à envahir
la moutète
j'attendais que ça je passais mon temps
à dire on était un quart d'heure de
l'angleterre
et il n'y a rien à faire et on n'arrive
pas à trouver une solution et donc voilà
si c'est mme li est arrivé avec son
projet c'est génial 35 minutes entre
coquelles côté français et folkestone
côté anglais pour nos vieux routier la
traversée de la manche dans un tunnel
est désormais d'une affligeante banalité
j'arrivais recommandations à leur parti
en quoi les uniformes mise à part nadia
lucas et les autres sont invités à
chanter lire et penser en angle si les
paroles viendront plus tard la gestuelle
elle est universelle en angleterre à
l'heure du déjeuner il peut être
salutaire de savoir dire non avec la
tête
no mercy même si les spécialités locales
sont apprécié
dgo pour 140 francs la journée il y a
même au programme l'incontournable leçon
de cricket cette discipline aux règles
incompréhensible pour toute personne
saine de corps et l'esprit en six mois
l'expérience l'entente cordiale
fonctionne déjà à plein régime le plus
important n'étant pas pour l'instant
l'apprentissage de la langue de
shakespeare
plus que la halle à 14h30 alexandra
rentrer à calais des millions de choses
à raconter d'autres inconsciemment
d'enregistrer il semaine après semaine
lui donneront sans doute cette
conviction que l'anglais n'est pas une
langue si difficile à apprendre surtout
lorsque l'on habite juste de l'autre
bout du tunnel une campagne
d'information et de prévention sur
l'asthme organisé par l'ordre des
pharmaciens à près de trois millions
d'asthmatiques sont concernés par cette
campagne depuis 30 ans le nombre
d'enfants souffrant d'asthme a augmenté
d'environ 6 à 10% une maladie qui touche
pour un tiers jeunes et adolescents
reportage
françoise valait alain look at you seen
10 à 15 ans ses parents sont
asthmatiques et tout naturellement elle
se pose des questions sur la je vais
vous remettre les deux documents que
nous avons alors rien un document s'il
dit reçoit des informations et peut
procéder à un test gratuit qui permet de
contrôler sa capacité respiratoire ou
vous allez souffler dans l'embout comme
si vous vouliez éteindre une bougie
rené bien votre respiration et ensuite
vous soufflez voilà parfait sans souffle
est normal cindy est rassuré en cas de
problème le pharmacien lui aurait
conseillé de voir un médecin
en france on estime à 3 millions le
nombre d'asthmatiques mais beaucoup de
personnes surtout les jeunes ignorent
qu'elles ont de l'as souvent le dé la
justice parce qu'on ne pas porter
parce que les parents ont peur de ce mot
alors que le pouvoir plus cher c'est fou
et un temps révolu
on part soit pas bien interpréter des
symptômes ou parce que les parents
croient qu'il s'agit de bronchite simple
qui ne nécessite pas une consultation
médicale en plus tôt la maladie est
détectée plus il est facile de la
soigner aujourd'hui les traitements sont
relativement simples mais les patients
ne savent pas toujours bien les
utilisent
au moment où tu appuies problèmes
techniques les miches achats de
médicaments
et puis il ya le problème de
l'observance
il est fréquent que bon leur enfant se
soigne pas qu'une crise et puis ensuite
de la tête
il ya pourtant un traitement bien suivi
permet d'avoir une vie normale et même
très sportives ne sont au mark spitz et
l'alpiniste catherine destivelle sont
tous les deux de grands asthmatiques
fin du voyage de bill clinton en afrique
du sud quelques heures avant son départ
pour le botswana bill et hillary clinton
ont assisté à une messe à soweto où le
prêtre avait choisi pour serment le
thème de l'adultère que le couple
présidentiel à côté avant de communier
bill clinton qui dans le milieu de la
journée donc arrivé dans la capitale du
botswana avant dernière étape de sa
tournée africaine
aux etats unis le secrétaire d'état
américaine madeleine albright déclaré
hier que le processus de paix
israélo-palestinien était au bord de
l'effondrement
alors que dennis ross l'émissaire
américain au proche-orient entame sa
troisième journée de consultations avec
benjamin netanyahu la situation est sur
le terrain extrêmement tendue charles
enderlin un premier ministre sous
pression
c'est la première fois depuis des années
qu'un secrétaire d'état américain
critique aussi durement la politique
israélienne
fini les sourires comme ici en septembre
dernier lors de la visite de madeleine
albright à jérusalem
aujourd'hui elle affirme que le refus de
monsieur netanyahu d'accepter un retrait
de 13 % de la cisjordanie porte atteinte
à la crédibilité des etats-unis au
proche-orient
à washington on craint en effet une
explosion
de violences dans la région où la
tension est très vive
un exemple aujourd'hui dans le sud de la
bande de gaza des manifestants
palestiniens tentent de planter des
oliviers sur un terrain confisqué par
l'armée israélienne les soldats
israéliens casque et s'y opposent les
militaires palestiniens à béret vert ne
riposte pas gardent leur sang-froid
l'affrontement armé et évité de justesse
dennis ross le médiateur américain tente
de désamorcer la crise il poursuit ses
entretiens avec benyamin nétanyahou et
yasser arafat pour le processus de paix
ce sont peut-être les négociations de la
dernière chance
en algérie les forces de sécurité
auraient tué 70 islamistes lors
d'opérations de représailles opérations
qui se sont déroulés ce week end dans
l'une des provinces où les massacres du
ramadan avaient été les plus odieux
selon la presse une centaine
d'islamistes aurait été par ailleurs à
siéger en irak apparition surprise de
saddam hussein en rendant visite à des
habitants de deux villages dans le
centre du pays
le chef de l'état a tiré des salves en
l'air en signe de joie alors que des
villageois célébrer sa venue par des
chants traditionnels la télévision
irakienne a diffusé ces images
inhabituelles
alors que les experts de luxe comme
inspectés sont à l'aide de qik est sa
ville natale aux états unis violentes
tornades dans l'illinois plusieurs
maisons étaient totalement détruite de
nombreux dégâts pour cette tornade qui
se déplaçait sur un kilomètre de long
balayant tout sur son passage
on évoque souvent l'influencé positive
des animaux sur le traitement de
maladies psychiques comme certaines des
pressions voire même d'autisme
même si l'on continue à s'interroger sur
les bienfaits réels de ces thérapies je
vous propose de suivre l'histoire de cet
enfant de 8 ans qui a prononcé ses
premiers mots après avoir passé quelques
jours dans un centre médical de miami
avec des dauphins le christ peau
s'il te plaît plongeon de dans une
expression 2 me ce fut le bonheur pour
les parents d'unity en huit ans ils
n'étaient jamais sorties de fonds monde
du silence
et ce sont les dauphins de ce centre de
miami qui l'ont aidé à parler il m'a
regardé il m'a dit que dans j'ai insisté
pour que le pain clairement j'ai posé
mes mains sur son visage comme ça il
articulé dedans j'ai assisté et ensuite
ça criait donnant à el al en israël un
autre centre utilise de thérapie
extraordinaire trois dauphins joue les
instructeurs auprès de jeunes patients
autistes et à chaque fois le contact
s'établit les dauphins font passer des
sons aux autistes que nous entendons ça
c'est sûr nous le voyons nous
enregistrons les parents de cet autre
petit garçon billy lui aussi muet
aimerait bien que le miracle se
reproduise un miracle qui a un prix
élevé cent mille francs les trois
semaines du séjour américain
ceci explique peut-être les réticences
d'autres spécialistes des dauphins ils
redoutent de voir naître trop vite des
espoirs thérapeutiques
c'est une expérience inoubliable de se
baigner avec les confins de jouer avec
les dauphins ric et de les voir on voit
que les gens son avis juste de les voir
en vrai c'est un animal qui fabule donc
sa marque c'est clair n'importe quel
enfant celui-ci voulu donner quelque
chose qui lui plaît beaucoup et ensuite
me l'enlever c'est clair qu'il va crier
et à vraiment c'est ce qui s'est passé
philibert clown c'est sûr qui permet de
ça le milieu médical se montrent
extrêmement prudents et pourtant ni qui
a parlé
l'homme des glaces surnommé hibernatus
cette momie vieille de 5300 ans est
exposée au public pour la première fois
dans un sarcophage réfrigérée dans le
nord de l'italie une fenêtre d'environ
50 cm installées à l'intérieur de la
cellule réfrigéré à -6 degrés et avec
une humilité proche de 100% permettent
aux visiteurs d'admirer la dépouille de
cet homme de l'âge de bronze
la découverte remonte à 1991 où l'homme
avait été trouvée sur un glacier des
dolomites
à paris la foire du trône pour la
dernière fois sur la pelouse de reuilly
dans le bois de vincennes les fora
redoute ce déménagement imposé par la
mairie pour raisons de sécurité
avec eux c'est toute une page de
l'histoire de la fête foraine qui se
tourne
reportage louis carzou bruno livertout
c'est sans doute une première mais si la
roue tourne cette année à la foire du
trône c'est un peu au désespoir des
forains
car après 34 ans de présence sur la
pelouse de reuilly au bois de vincennes
la mairie de paris a décidé tout seul de
faire déménager la fête vers d'autres
cieux
un arrêté qui n'a pas vraiment le goût
de gros lot et qui donne déjà un regard
nostalgique aux habitués du lieu je
pense pas qu'on ira parce que la foire
du trône c'est une foire parisienne et
je crois qu'il faut maintenir l'esprit
que paris doit garder ça fait d'abord et
puis faut nécessairement qui s'adresse
une foire parisienne
tu vois pas comment on pourrait dire
appelez-la la foire du trône de créteil
où la foire du trône aubervilliers alors
en attendant la nomination d'un
médiateur avec lequel ils doivent
prendre longue sur leur sort les
quelques 2000 forains de la foire du
trône estime que ce déménagement risque
de pousser leurs 5 millions de fidèles
aux dernières extrémités
en clair ne plus venir à la fête ben moi
ça représente 60 % de mon chiffre
d'affaires de l'année quoi parce que si
vous voulez c'est là c'est la meilleure
voie la meilleure fête de france pour
nous et puis c'est une tradition
une tradition que parisiens et
parisiennes pourront tout de même goûté
cette année jusqu'au 1er juin avec un
record à battre l'an dernier il s'est
consommé la bac 90 tonnes de fric de
gaufres de chichi de croustillantes
à
sport à présent le tirage au sort des
demi finales de la coupe de france de
football ont eu lieu ce matin le paris
saint germain affrontera guingamp et
lens le club de lyon ces deux matches se
joueront le 11 avril
en tennis l'américaine venus williams a
remporté cette nuit le tournoi de key
biscayne en floride
venus williams s'est imposée en trois
sets 2 6 6 4 6 1 face à la russe anna
kournikova l'américaine âgée de 17 ans
remporte le deuxième titre de sa
carrière et prend la 10e place au
classement mondial
cinéma avec le dernier film de tarantino
l'enfant chéri du cinéma américain qui a
signé défi ou comme reservoir dogs pulp
fiction palme d'or à cannes
aujourd'hui quentin tarantino revient
avec jacky braun des fusils des combines
les deux là rappeler demain en apparence
son univers n'a pas changé et une fois
encore une affiche de rêve avec robert
de niro verrier de l'ère roger motte
rien et ça va nous séparent et moi et
moi car faut surtout se méfier les
imitations quentin tarantino en sait
quelque chose lui qui excelle à toujours
prendre les tournants où on ne l'attend
pas si vous aviez l'occasion de [ __ ]
le camp avec un demi million $ ce qui
vous le feriez une question d'importance
avec l jackie brown répond très vite à
40 ans cette femme intelligente se lasse
d'une vie médiocre qu'elle améliore en
convoyant de l'argent pas bien pourquoi
cours un trafiquant d'armes subir pour
luisant ça vous gêne pas
c'est que ça me gêne pas parce que j'ai
le choix bien faire vous avez le droit
de dire non non toujours où elle se fait
pincer jackie brown décide de changer de
destin dans un monde où le train de la
chance si leurs armes en plusieurs fois
c'est ma mère était célibataire c'est
elle qui malgré elle a été un exemple
très fort c'est pour cela que je suis
toujours en admiration et attirer les
femmes de tarantino a le talent de
rendre inimitable des histoires au
demeurant ordinaire dans l'amérique
d'aujourd'hui les avec ce fils lui il
montre qu'il sait aussi parler d'amour
car dans sa course au magot jackie brown
sera trouvé un allié de coeur pour
lutter contre des flics hargneux et une
bande d'escrocs aussi dangereux qu'un
imbécile je veux bien aller voir poupée
sexy pour toi attention au pij fast food
en tube halo c'est pour toi
si vous enlevez tout la grèce le
superflu et que vous faites bouillir la
viande la chair qui reste vous trouverez
un noyau comme une terre où elle réside
à quelle est cette perle bien en faisant
la même chose avec mon film c'est une
histoire d'amour avant tout on n'a pas
lésiné sur le piment pour concocter
cette histoire beaucoup de délires de
fantaisie et une distribution
époustouflante faut que jackie brown
s'impose comme un hommage briand à la
série b les jardins de bagatelle ont en
ce moment une allures d'arche de noé les
sculpteurs claude et françois lalanne
ont peuplé les bosquets les bassins de
leurs animaux une belle rétrospective
pour ces artistes qui sont associés dans
la vie et dans l'art de pia demi siècle
reportage georges bigot et jean-louis me
là nous ne sommes pas dans la campagne
anglaise près d'un troupeau de moutons à
tête noire mais dans les jardins de
bagatelle interdit c'est dommage on
s'amuse bien ici il ya des poissons qui
vole les bocana beau métal quichotte
puis les oiseaux qui regardent les
façons il ya des gens qui drague 11
écailles de feuilles tout un bestiaire
sorti de l'imagination de claude et
françois xavier lalanne
ce couple de sculpteurs est
indissociable et malgré leurs styles
différents
on dit toujours les lalanne toutefois
dans leur ferme non loin de paris d
lalanne fonds d'atelier à part
après
première fois que j'ai travaillé le
métal j'ai cru que c'était une matière
atrocement difficile mais pas du tout ça
se travaille très facilement
on peut plier on peut le penser le coupé
et ça s'est très facilement
il ya beaucoup de végétaux et parce que
d'abord j'ai un jardin jardiner j'aime
par ces liseuses
j'essaie toujours que les choses restent
vis pas cela du fait que les factures du
fait de perdre et animaux du fait d'être
il y aura t'il complètement figuratif
comme ce petit garçon il vous arrivera
peut-être de croiser les lalanne à
baguette
n'hésitez pas le souvenir aura de la
valeur si d'après comment dans la cpo
vous êtes sûre en tout cas de rencontrer
leurs oeuvres qui font depuis longtemps
le bonheur des jardins et des musées des
grandes capitales la fin de ce journal
je vous rappelle les principaux titres
en formule 1 mika qui ne remporte le
grand prix du brésil suivi par david
coulthard victoire écrasante des mclaren
mercedes le plus grand pont de l'europe
un trait d'union vers le futur avec
l'inauguration près de lisbonne de
secours de 17 km de long construit par
une entreprise française
dans un instant la météo nathalie
rouille rihouet puis à 20h55 harcèlement
avec des mii moore et michael douglas
demain à 7h50 dans les 4 vérités marie
pierre farkas recevra jean jacques
queyranne
je vous remercie de votre attention
demain soir vous retrouverez daniel
bilalian excellente de fin de soirée sur
france 2
ce